technical leadership
what comes to your mind when you hear
these two words
as the name suggests the technical
leadership role consists of two main
responsibilities
technical responsibility and leadership
activity
in most organizations senior developers
who perform well are eventually asked to
lead a team and deliver results through
that team
they often become chief technology
officers and vice presidents of
engineering
some senior developers decide to take a
risk leave their organizations and
launch their own software startups
developers often assume new leadership
roles because of their deep technical
expertise that enabled them to perform
well in their technical roles
however after they become managers a lot
of them fail to become effective leaders
but why is that what many do not realize
is that leading requires an entirely new
set of traits
if you want to become a great tech lead
one day stay tuned as i explore the top
10 traits of the great technical leaders
first great technical leaders align
their teams with the company's vision
goals and strategy
each organization has an established
mission vision and strategy
vision defines long-term goals while
strategy formulates the ways of
achieving those objectives
great technical leaders know how to
communicate general companies vision
with their product design and technical
teams as well as align technical road
maps with the company's objectives in
order to maximize long-term shareholders
value
goals could include things like tripling
the user base increasing average revenue
per user by 40 percent doubling an
average user session or improving
loading times by 25 percent
based on specific objectives technical
leaders are able to define the direction
of the tech stack development what
features should be prioritized what
processes should be automated
what teams should be grown in-house
versus which should be outsourced and
what software components should be built
versus what should be bought
second great technical leaders know how
to establish trust and psychological
safety in their teams
google conducted a comprehensive
multi-year internal study to identify
the key factors that made their teams
more effective
psychological safety was far and away
the most important of the five dynamics
they found
so what happens when that all-important
psychological safety is absent in a tech
team
people become afraid to take risks and
innovate
they become more concerned with avoiding
mistakes than achieving big wins
developers tend to be naturally curious
independent creative and inventive
when you take away their autonomy they
feel cramped and unmotivated
when you let them relax and figure out
things on their own they blossom and
work magic
great technical leaders know that trust
and psychological safety is extremely
important in order to ensure a high
level of productivity of their technical
teams
three
great technical leaders know how to work
through failures and celebrate wins
technical leaders know that things will
fail deploys will fail schedules will be
missed
crashes will happen
however technical leaders do not worry
too much about failure
when things break great technical
leaders stay calm and don't look for
someone to blame
instead they take responsibility and use
their energy to fix the problem at hand
and learn from it
learning from failure shapes their
orientation and makes for better
decision making in the future
when an important feature is shipped or
a sprint is finished technical leaders
congratulate individual contributors as
well as organize fun activities with
their teams such as happy hours and teen
building activities
they know how to appreciate their team
members encourage them motivate them and
keep them happy
four
great technical leaders stay technical
one of the responsibilities of the
technical leaders is to oversee the
technical excellence of their products
to effectively accomplish this objective
great technical leaders stay technical
at all times
they are technically fearless and no
technical problem is impossible for them
they continuously work to expand both
the depth and breadth of their knowledge
in the problem domain technology and
best practices to keep up with the
growing demands of their work
technical leaders are either technically
the best of their teams or one of the
best
as such technical leaders define
technical vision for their products make
decisions on the technical stack
security and deployment practices as
well as are involved in code reviews and
technical mentoring of their staff
five technical leaders are biased for
action
knowledge and skills without action are
not sufficient to produce desired
outcome
therefore the top technical leaders
strive to be action oriented they
prioritize their tasks and act
immediately based on their priorities
actions are taken using practical tools
and processes
using a quick phone call rather than
writing a long email for example can be
more effective in acting for a priority
matter
sometimes bringing various stakeholders
in the same room with a clear agenda for
a short period of time can help resolve
a complicated matter quickly
excellent technical leaders are not only
action oriented by themselves but they
also enable others to become
action-oriented by facilitating the
activities making the approach easier
clearing the hurdles and providing a
clear vision
they value team consensus but in the
case of a prolonged technical discussion
without a decision technical leads drive
their teams to action
6.
technical leaders are quick learners
learning is a lifelong process
great technical leaders are quick
learners and they use every situation as
a learning opportunity
all quick learners have two
characteristics in common
first they are quick thinkers quick to
see problems and issues and quick to
imagine potential solutions
second they know how to collect
information from multiple sources turn
them into insight and bring practical
and real results using them
quick learners tend to pay more
attention to nuances think more
systemically and learn and apply
experiences to future possibilities
as a result they are more nimble and
effective in adapting recognizing and
anticipating problems early as well as
solving them responsively and
holistically
technical leads are balanced pragmatic
and realistic
they use their quick learning ability
judgment and experience to choose the
right trade-offs among competing
approaches
seven
great technical leaders are effective
communicators
they know that it is always better to
over communicate rather than under
communicate
effective communication is an inevitable
aspect of leading people dealing with
situations effectively and setting the
strategies for transformations
effective communication requires
unbiased listening understanding others
point of views and conveying the message
to the point in the right context
clarity is one of the critical enablers
of effective communication
using the right words in the right
context refraining from jargon and
ambiguous words are essential to
effective communication
excellent leaders articulate the
situations
however they do not just trust the power
of their communication but they also
find ways to validate the understanding
of other people
more importantly they follow up with
team members and other stakeholders
whether the message is understood and
appropriate actions are taken
eight great technical leaders are the
champions of understanding the why of
their work
they strive to understand where their
technical efforts fall into the
high-level business objectives
they also always keep their technical
teams aligned with the mission vision
and strategic goal nine great technical
leaders are self-aware
to be a self-aware leader you must know
who you are before you can look at
yourself in the context of your company
or in the context of your peers
you cannot be an effective leader
without emotional intelligence and
self-awareness
understanding yourself and your own
limitations what you are good at what
you are not good at is critical to
ensure you are surrounding yourself with
the right people
knowing this will allow you to better
focus on the people you interact with so
that you can recognize and interpret
what's happening within them and manage
your interactions with them based on
their emotions
a strong emotional intelligence
separates average from outstanding
technical leaders and is just as
important as iq
finally great technical leaders know how
to inspire lead and influence people
great technical leaders realize that the
key to success is deeply rooted in the
positive empowering leadership behaviors
that inspire people
you see a good leader can inspire people
to have confidence in the leader
a great leader can inspire people to
have confidence in themselves
today's technical experts are poised to
make strong influential leaders
to do so however they must rely on more
than their technical expertise
if you found this video useful i would
appreciate it if you smash the like
button
also make sure to subscribe to the
coding tech channel and click on the
notification bell
enjoy the rest of your day